We know equations are like scales. They need to remain balanced. The left side
needs to equal the right. There are some choices we can make along the way to
help us with our math. Let's see what those are. I'm going to solve this problem
two ways. When thinking about solving this equation, I'm going to combine my
like terms on one side of the equation. So here, I'll have 3b plus 32 and then
on the right side, I'll have 2b plus 47. I've listed my equation twice, so now
that I can solve it two different ways. First, we can subtract 2b from both
sides. 3b and negative 2b make positive 1b. I have 1 times b here, but I don't
really need to write the 1. I can leave it off. The positive 32 comes straight
down, positive 2b and negative 2b sum to 0, so I don't list anything here. And
then, I have positive 47. In the end, b equals positive 15. But let's see
another way to solve this. I subtracted 2b first, but what if I didn't subtract
the 2b, what if I subtracted the 3b? Positive 3b and negative 3b makes 0, the 32
comes down, the 47 comes down and then 2b and negative 3b make negative 1b. And
subtracting 47, we get negative 1b is equal to negative 15. So, I'm not
interested in the negative value of b, I want to know the positive value of b.
So, I know if negative b is negative 15, then positive b must be positive 15.
that could also think about multiplying both sides by a negative 1, That would
give us our result, b equals positive 15. So, when you're solving equations,
it's best to look out for the variables. Do you want to keep your variable
positive? Or do you want to make it negative? It's probably easier to work with
a positive b variable here. Sometimes, we make errors with negative signs, so
it's best to avoid those.